uh let's uh now speak to christopher
wilson he's a royal biographer and
commentator he joins me now from devon
good to have you on the program
your reaction to uh what we're hearing
at the moment
well of course i think we just have to
wait and see how things go but uh
i've been speaking to people in scotland
and i think that we can
take it that the queen's life is coming
to an end
um
tell us a little bit about uh
how she's been doing recently i mean
we've been hearing about
uh how she's had some mobility issues
which is why she's been uh based in
balmoral rather than sort of traveling
to the traveling to london which she
normally would have
what are you hearing about that
well i i i think what is remarkable
about this uh sovereign is that she has
clung to
uh the throne and to her job until the
very last moment i think we can see that
her powers have been declining for the
last year at the very least
and she has done a very very good job in
managing uh
what she's able to do
and putting from her things that she
wasn't able to do she's gone on far
longer than anybody could expect her to
do she's 96 years old and she's doing uh
which she has done all that she possibly
can to retain the strings of power and
the very idea that she was able to stand
upright a couple of days ago and greet
the new prime minister it would have
been an
iron will and determination on her part
that she should do that to show that she
is still sovereign until the moment she
dies
indeed a very beautiful heartwarming
picture uh and liz truss will have been
glad to meet her on that day
i mean she she she's such an important
person isn't she for the people of the
united kingdom and people all over
why
give us a sense i mean your royal
biographer why does she mean so much to
so many
i think that uh
she is a thread of continuity which has
taken the nation through i mean there
are people who are 80 or 90 years old in
great britain uh who
as it were saw this princess become a
queen and have lived with her uh through
thick and thin through changing times
all that time it's very reassuring in in
a changing world that some things remain
the same
and then for each new generation that's
come people have been born and died
within the space of her reign she has
always been there she is a constant in
people's lives in this country she has
meant so much
let's talk a little bit about her
husband prince philip who
had been by her side
from a very very long time from when she
was in her early 20s
he's been he he was with her throughout
the entire time he stood by her side how
difficult
do you think it's been for her since
losing him
i i think that we can see there was a
turn in the road at the moment that he
died at that point uh she weakened
perceptibly uh and perfectly
understandably i mean he had stood by
her he had been her support the only
person really in the whole royal family
that she could trust and rely on and uh
you know the loss of him at her
extremely
advanced age was really more uh than she
was able to cope with but and and so
what we saw was this slight retreat but
it was nothing like the retreat of other
uh sovereigns in other times she kept on
doing what she could do she kept on
being as visible as she could she
mastered
doing zoom meetings uh
and so forth in order to be able to keep
in contact with the outside world and to
show that she was still queen it was
quite a remarkable act but of course the
loss of prince philip really did change
the game yes she was absolutely
incredible always looked
fantastic at her best in the most
beautiful of clothes of suits uh and as
you say
even two days ago yeah uh she had this
astonishing smile there has been a
political turmoil in britain for the
last three or four months
and
her vision of
the politicians which serve this country
must possibly have deteriorated
and yet she greeted the new prime
minister with a wonderful welcoming
smile and a handshake she was even
carrying her signature handbag even
though
there was no need for that but you know
she was determined to show that the show
still goes on indeed it was such a
wonderful picture
britain of course going through a very
very difficult time the people of the
united kingdom we've been talking about
the the the high cost of living the
energy bills it's it's such a difficult
time for them
and the queen of course means so much to
so many i mean it couldn't this sort of
news couldn't come at a worse time could
it
i think that's absolutely right i mean
we have as you say we've gone through a
very difficult time recently uh and
rather like uh the the king and queen
during the second world war george vi
and the green mother
uh
if everything was really horrible what
you could do is rest your thoughts on
something neutral and mildly glamorous
and and
rest your mind and the queen provided
that in these times all the way through
covered all the way through uh the
problems which we've had to face ever
since she's been a constant something
that is non-controversial non-political
uh and uh just something that you can
rest your mind on and feel good about
uh you are a biographer uh and i i i
just want to ask you
the way things are being handled at the
moment the fact that we we received the
statement from buckingham palace
uh we know that prince charles
is there with her in balmoral uh and
prince william is on his way there i
mean
what do you read into all that i mean
what do you think is happening
um well i think that the
the fact that we are being told uh that
charles is on his way that william is on
his way i think that
the palace never wants to create a sense
of anxiety around the royal family what
they try to do is downplay everything
but i think the fact that they are now
saying uh that the uh
next king
and his successor are on the way uh to
balmoral suggests that we are now
entering the last phase of the queen's
life and we don't know how long that
will be and
many will hope that she will recover but
i think that
she has served her country for nearly
100 years
and there must come a time when her life
comes to an end
indeed uh
if it is indeed does come to that it's a
very very sad moment uh
talk us through the procedure what
exactly happens
if the queen does pass away
well there's a highly elaborate uh
set of instructions
it's called operation london bridge and
what it will do is over the next few
days it if the queen should die
there is a highly regimented and well
organized uh
state arrangement
which will take us through her lying in
state
um
her funeral uh her memorial service uh
and the various uh uh public occasions
which will uh close around the end of
her reign um it's all been organized for
a very long time she's been aware of all
the things that are going to happen she
will have put her name to all this so uh
there will be no surprises for those
around the royal family as to what's
going to happen next it's all being set
in train
okay uh christopher wilson royal
biographer really good to get your
thoughts uh joining us there from devon
in the united kingdom